[Applause]
can you explain something to me you did
something that was magical and i truly
don't understand it and i tried to look
it up and i went off of your explanation
i thought it was really brilliant but
i had that issue with my achilles
because we were back flipping in
columbus right because that's how many
things there are to do in colombia
[Music]
we were so bored we were like should we
just learn out of backwards try to kill
ourselves yeah
that might be better uh and i like
i thought i tweaked my achilles and i
was really nervous because i was like oh
god i get nervous about the idea of like
doing any long-term recovery yeah
i'm just like i don't want to tweak it
so i kind of like laid off of it for a
little while i first was working out and
it would continue getting sore
and i come in and you asked me a few
questions about the achilles it was
really sore like
it was really bad and then you start
squeezing around
my [ __ ] leg yeah you locate that it's
not
really achilles it was tibialis
posterior tibialis posterior
and you keep touching it and now it's
good i don't feel
bad at all prior to that and i haven't
changed the way that i've been
exercising i haven't taken more time off
you just squeeze my leg and now it's
better yeah
the average person myself included
doesn't understand what the [ __ ]
happened right
you explained it to me can you explain
to people
at home what happened right all right so
an injury is applied force greater than
tissue tolerance
that's the applied force greater than
tissue tolerance greater than tissue
tolerance so the tissue can tolerate a
certain amount of force and this is too
much force to that tissue
that's every injury and that's every
issue okay so so like imagine
like you got stabbed applied force of
the knife greater than the tissue
tolerance of the skin and the muscle
breaks the skin yeah
breaks the muscle yeah okay so our body
like when we learn biomechanics if you
go down this rabbit hole yeah oftentimes
biomechanics gets taught with these
things called
like free body diagrams they're two
dimensional depictions you see a little
stick figure the guy squatting
and it's like well the front squat is
more upright because the bar is here and
then the knee is this and if your leg is
this big then your torso goes to this
angle
like that's not actually biomechanics
that's mechanics right because that's
two two-dimensional it's a
two-dimensional picture
yeah we're three-dimensional beings
we're moving through three planes and we
also
move through a dimension of time yeah
biomechanics is going to take into
into account your nervous system as well
100 right so it's like
our body like if you look at how nerves
sort of fire and how they're laid out in
their body it's not necessarily these
straight lines like
classical mechanics is moving between
the shortest distance between two points
as a straight straight line right so we
can take these angles and these rulers
and draw this and be like oh your
your torque is this or your lever arm or
moment arm is this
distance and therefore divide by pi and
then this is the amount of newton meters
of force you have to produce or whatever
[ __ ] it is yeah
and that doesn't that doesn't come off
the white board right that doesn't come
onto the gym floor
right that's all purely theoretical
two-dimensional
mechanics yeah biomechanics is
understanding that okay our body kind of
works like lightning
right where it's like it finds the path
of least resistance right these
neurological impulses are electrical
right like ionic channels and
depolarization all that [ __ ] so it's
like we need to just figure out
why is that we're converging so much
force on this tissue that seems to be
intolerant to it rather than just trying
to strengthen the tissue itself
a lot of people get injured it's like oh
my knee hurts i have a batella
tendinitis
my achilles hurts maybe i tore it like
that was an early concern of yours like
maybe i tore my achilles and like that's
a no joke injury yeah yeah or
anyway little i had a little tear and i
was like oh my god you don't want to be
big
achilles are wrong like career enders
yeah achilles suck if you don't know
what you're doing so it's like
well you just seem to have irritation
and for some reason
our body is choosing this path of least
resistance that's applying
too much force to that so i look at that
and go okay like
if this nervous system kind of works
like lightning rather than these
straight lines
how is it that we can maybe like diverge
some of this force away from the
achilles what else is kind of in the
region that may be
acting like a lightning rod that should
be acting like a lightning rod
to draw in some of this force that may
be kind of decommissioned based off of
the way you rolled your ankle
trying to backflip in columbus okay
right so it's like i've dealt with
enough
ankles and feet and not like the way you
guys deal with feet
but like i've dealt with enough which
has totally ruined how i look at people
now yeah by the way so thank you for
that
he gave me like a phd level dissertation
in the toes and i was just like i went
home and i was just like looked at tests
and like my
girlfriend is gorgeous she's amazing
she's the best and i look at her feet
and i just literally thought
[ __ ] you are gone carried on with my day
but it's like so it's what else is in
the lower leg that
should be accepting this force yeah
right so tibialis posterior can work in
a similar fashion
to the the gastroc and the soleus which
connect onto the achilles tendon so if
we can
kind of get this back online if we can
get our bodies like hey let's actually
start using this tibialis posterior
again
to do what tibialis posteriors do we're
going to no longer converge all that
force into the achilles
right so it's like i just need to rewire
your path least resistance so the
analogy i always use
and we were talking about this yesterday
i think i'll probably explain it to all
of you by now
is like uh motion capture the idea of a
motion capture system that
you know whether it's creating nba 2k10
or whatever or
they have those black suits and little
balls on them and then yeah
and it goes to a computer and then we
can overlay a skin of the character on
top of the movements
and make it really realistic our body
has that our body has that internally
like we have these things called muscle
spindles that relay proprioception and
allows us in our mind
so when i can't see where my hand is i
know where my hand is
because my central processor my computer
is my brain yeah so without visually
seeing this i know where it is
so when you rolled your ankle you kind
of like took a few of those ping pong
balls and kind of put them offline
right so you're kind of getting this
error message as your body starts to try
and
fill in that image in space and that
error message is getting perceived i
roll my ankle
right and i damage some of those
ping-pong balls right those ping-pong
balls are the things that
uh accept messages and send messages
to the brain right right so because
they're damaged
they're not accepting or sending any
messages and therefore the only
ping-pong ball that's left you're saying
was like the achilles one
yeah more like and you're just getting
an error message filling in from that
expected transmission from the one
that's missed
and then the error message is pain right
so we're feeling this pain but that's
just the way that our body says that
there is something wrong
it might not necessarily mean that the
the region itself
that i'm feeling the pain is broken it
could be something else that's been
affected is that what happened so yeah
you you heal
an injury but you unlearn pain and
oftentimes there's a middle ground of
this venn diagram
right so like low back issues are really
common one so like
lumbar spine disc herniation yeah yeah
and 25
of people that are asymptomatic that
don't have low back pain
have herniated discs on an mri so it's
not this n equals one relationship with
like herniated disc equals pain
so it's like you've found a way to like
out function that damaged structure
right so yes you do need to a certain
degree to heal
tissues to not feel pain because there
is an overlap in like that unlearning
versus healing process
pain process but they're not completely
superimposed in the same thing
okay so then when you squeeze my leg
right
not near the achilles no at the tip post
at the tip post
you were engaging the ping pong balls
again yes
right back we talked about like
proprioceptors being one and that's
stability work so whenever we're doing
like lunges
or things like that and your foot's out
we were talking about this last night
you know your foot's trying to like
catch your
femur basically like trying to stabilize
athletics yeah
that's yeah yeah panic stuff right so
proprioceptors are one of those
ping-pong balls but we have specific
inputs that are for like deep pressure
stimuli yeah so if i go in and
what i did is grab your tip post i was
like yo like ah [ __ ] really hurt
that's kind of like there's a there's a
nerve ending that acts to feed into this
high resolution hopefully high
resolution motion capture within our own
brain and where our foot is
so deep pressure is one heat is another
vibration is another like those
thera gun and maybe that's a branded
term i just don't want to
the the jigsaw looking things that are
right i'm sure they have my berries
yeah they have them like crossfit gyms
we got them up at hoa
and the reason that they're effective is
because we actually have nerve endings
that are specific to receiving
and then sort of engaging this
transmission process that's specific to
vibration
there's some vibration deep pressure
heat
light touches that acupuncture does
acupuncture similar kind of like
accidentally did they fall into
success yeah i don't know much about
acupuncture
but functioning in the same way right
i'm going to bring a lot of attention to
these specific regions and then maybe
we'll fire up those receptors that for
whatever reason are damaged or not
acceptable it's the only i mean it's not
like how necessarily a profession works
or a discipline it's just how your
nervous system works
right right so they're everything that
we perceive has a
transmission and a receiver right right
that's how it gets to our brain yeah
acupuncture is probably just a
combination
of those things and simultaneously
getting these
feedbacks of these inputs from these
different receptors but we have all
these different
locks that kind of turn the same key
right so it's like
stretching can do it right and the tip
post is a little bit difficult to get to
because of the way like the ankle has to
move and the knee has to move to get
into a position to actually stretch it
but like there's a stretch receptor so
like just a conventional stretch of like
taking origin insertion of a muscle and
moving it away from one another
right that's another input that helps us
create
this hopefully high resolution very
accurate depiction of where we are in
space so you have different receptors
that feedback based off of the stimulus
input
that they receive right some are just
wired for vibration some are just wired
for deep pressure some are just wired
for
heat some are just wired for some are
just wired for pain yeah some are
just wired for proprioception some are
wired for deep pressure or sorry
um for stretch so all of these different
things are all ways that we can
externally kind of
hopefully manipulate strategically to
start bringing this
this back online now it breaks down one
degree
further and this is where it gets i
think pretty interesting is
that we can base our progressions off
the speed in which these things are
transmitted
right so stability which like this is
something that i've probably harped on
with all of you
at some point in time like that word i
really mean proprioception
and proprioception moves faster in your
body so that muscle spindle reflex that
one particular nerve ending that pathway
from
that ping-pong ball to the brain moves
faster than
other pathways right so the deep
pressure pathway
the vibration pathway they move a little
bit slower pain actually moves the
slowest 6 to 30 meters per second
so like a pain transmission that's
filling in the gaps for a transmission
that's missing from another one of these
receptors with
these transmitters up into the brain
pain moves 6 to 30 meters per second
which we think like all right bolts
running like 15 at max velocity 30 is
pretty fast
but if you think that proprioception
stability and like what's called the
golgi 10 organ reflex like stretch
reflex so stability drills and
stretching
they get transmitted the fastest upwards
of like 120 130 meters per second
so it's like if i want to beat pain to
the brain
this is really what what i'm gonna do so
for me it's like when we look at
mobility drills or we look at trying to
fix your
ankle it's like all right let's start
with some of something that's just a
tear
faster than pain if pain moves 6 to 30
meters per second
what is the next input that we can not
block necessarily but beat pain with or
what's the next thing that we can learn
that will then
beat pain or or just outrun pain to the
brain
and that's some of these like what all i
did was just grab your tip post and said
hey move your ankle around
right and that's deep pressure i just
took my thumb well why did it fix it
because that brought back online the
idea that your body can now use the
tibialis posterior
um before it just didn't well it just
funneled it just bypassed it right it
funneled the force into the achilles so
the achilles
because i literally just give context i
didn't do anything on the
on the foot for at least a week and a
half and it did nothing
it was still painful it sucked and you
squeezed it and it was better within a
week right
i don't know how the [ __ ] that happened
but now i'm understanding you just
re-engaged something you woke something
more or less yeah yeah and like there's
there's figure the body would know how
to do that by itself
well in what the body is doing is in
itself a self-preservation mechanism
ah it's like that thing is broken let me
not touch that let me go to the next
thing i mean there's like lizards that
like lose their tails like i'll [ __ ] it
and they're running
out of the tail i'm out rather than you
get the rest of me right so i think it
is a self-preservation mechanism it's a
it's an efficiency mechanism yeah
but now all of a sudden because we're in
a conventional mechanical model we would
look at this two-dimensional pitcher and
be like oh we do
we need a certain amount of newton
meters force of tissue tolerance at the
achilles yeah let's do eccentric loading
let's do plyometric let's do jumping
let's do all this stuff
let's just go at it with a steel rod and
try and like
scrape it a bunch it's like the issue
isn't the tissue tolerance of the
achilles
the issue is why are we applying so much
force to begin with
you